30 jahre mauerfall der bundestag
debattiert emotional über die
vergangenheit dieses landes und die
zukunft
schrecksekunde unter tage nach einer
explosion in einem bergwerk in
sachsen-anhalt können alle bergleute
gerettet werden bush feuer außer
kontrolle im osten australiens hält eine
rekordzahl von bränden feuerwehr und
bewohner in atem und bedroht zahlreiche
tiere
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber guten abend hinein
heute um 7 ihr nachrichtenüberblick
sport inklusive nachher mit kristin otto
mit zwei topspielen amt 30 jahre fall
der berliner mauer das thema heute im
deutschen bundestag und dort zeigt sich
bereits wie emotional dieser jahrestag
ist morgen dann die große feier in
berlin
das land guckt zurück und nach vorn ein
einschneidender tag in berlin sitzt im
moment so aus die vorbereitungen für die
feiern rund ums brandenburger tor ein
riesiger bunter zettel teppich ist die
attraktion geknüpft aus 30.000 kleinen
botschaften mit wünschen und forderungen
rund um die deutsche einheit
die historische wende war heute auch
thema im parlament für eine debatte und
grund für streit
frank buchwald berichtet es geht um
deutungshoheit im bundestag um freiheit
und ihre grenzen und um die menschen
deren leben der mauerfall von grund auf
verändert hat in falun aufstehen
trotzdem weitermachen viele ostdeutsche
haben diese zeitung der freiheit nach
der wiedervereinigung selbständig die
friedliche revolution habe viele
lebensentwürfe infrage gestellt es sei
jedoch ein rechtsstaat gewesen der die
diktatur der sed aufgearbeitet habe und
diejenigen die es betrifft können
verdammt froh sein dass der
freiheitliche rechtsstaat sie so viel
besser behandelt hat als sie ihre
politischen gegner in 40 jahren von der
linken versuch eine art ehrenrettung für
die ddr
es gab in ihr staatliches unrecht
trotzdem lehne ich den begriff des
unrechtsstaates ddr
die afd aggressiv meinungsfreiheit sei
heute wieder in gefahr klagt sie und
stellt sich in die tradition der bürger
nicht länger wir brauchen gewiss keine
umerziehung verdienen jeder der damals
vor 30 jahren
jeder der damals vor 30 jahren auf die
straße gegangen ist hat mehr für die
demokratie getan hat sie alle zusammen
in diesen phasen haften sonntagsreden
was für eine groteske anmaßung nicht sie
sind die erben von 1989
es sind die demokratischen parteien die
danach dieses land wieder aufgebaut
haben die verantwortung übernommen haben
einheit in freiheit sie sei vielen
menschen zu verdanken auch politikern
nicht jedoch der afc gegenüber menschen
wie helmut kohl den kanzler der
deutschen einheit sind sie ärmliche
gestalten 30 jahre mauerfall damals ein
tag der freude heute vor allem
nachdenklichkeit die mauer quer durch
deutschland so viele leben wären ohne
sie völlig anders verlaufen vor allem
die leben derjenigen die sich einfach
nicht mit dir abfinden wollten
flucht ausweisung ausreise wie viele
menschen genau über die jahre die ddr
verließen lässt sich nicht genau sagen
aber schätzungen gibt es schon in der
mauer zeit gelang es zirka einer million
ostdeutschen das land irgendwie
dauerhaft zu verlassen
auf verschiedenen wegen 40.000
sogenannte sperr brecher wagten die
flucht über die ostsee oder durch die
grenzanlagen an land 5000 davon über die
berliner mauer deutlich mehr captain
nach einem westbesuch nicht mehr zurück
aber es ging auch legal
zum teil wurden oppositionelle von der
ddr selbst ausgewiesen oder aus der haft
vom westen freigekauft
man konnte auch einen ausreiseantrag
stellen
der aber für die familie große nachteile
mit sich bringen konnte
etwa 300.000 personen sollen im jahr der
wende eine fluchtmöglichkeit gefunden
haben
bis die mauer im november schließlich
fiel noch im februar 1989 bei der letzte
flüchtende in berlin erschossen worden
ca 1000 menschen sollen nach schätzungen
ihren fluchtversuch nicht überlebt haben
es ist auch der richtige moment heute
auf den stand der deutschen einheit zu
gucken wo gibt es nach all den jahren
gemeinsamkeiten wo gibt es immer noch
unterschiede
matthias fornoff hat dazu ganz aktuelle
zahlen vom zdf politbarometer hallo
matija guten abend die entscheidung für
die wiedervereinigung selbst jedenfalls
die ist unstrittig 92 prozent sagen ja
das war richtig heute überwiegen die
gemeinsamkeiten das sehen wir hier
rechts sagt eine mehrheit von 53 prozent
bundesweit wohlgemerkt im osten
allerdings findet jeder zweite dass die
unterschiede überwiegen sehr
unterschiedlich auch die einschätzung ob
ostdeutsche als bürger zweiter klasse
behandelt werden
im westen sagen 79% das stimmt nicht
im osten dagegen stimmen 46 prozent dem
vorwurf zu 47 nicht einheit also ja aber
nicht alles läuft rund und dann gucken
wir noch auf die innenpolitik da steht
ja die cdu-vorsitzende und
bundesverteidigungsministerium schon
länger im fokus muss man sagen es gibt
jetzt neue umfragezahlen wen hätten denn
die anni oder anders gefragt mit wem
sehen denn die anhänger von cdu/csu ihre
größten chancen
ja die union muss sich in der tat noch
sortieren wer als kanzlerkandidat oder
kandidatin ins rennen geht
die chancen sind am größten mit annegret
kramp-karrenbauer das sagen nur acht
prozent 15 prozent setzen auf armin
laschet deutlich die meisten 35%
friedrich merz markus söder 14 jens
spahn 12 prozent
bei mir jetzt am sonntag schon
bundestagswahl wäre dann käme die union
auf 27 prozent minus 2 die spd
unverändert 14 afd +1 ebenfalls 14 fdp 7
plus 1 linke 10 plus 2 und die grünen 22
prozent minus 2 union und grüne
verlieren also trotzdem würde es reichen
für schwarz grün
doch einiges dabei an basis für
politische diskussionen
herzlichen dank matthias auch heute
abend wieder und noch mehr informationen
zum verhältnis zwischen ost und west und
alle grafiken des politbarometers
bekommen sie natürlich auf heute de und
natürlich nachher im heute journal
und jetzt die diskussion um die künftige
sicherheitspolitik in der welt und die
rolle die deutschland dabei spielt der
us außenminister forderte heute in
berlin
mehr engagement die deutsche
verteidigungsministerin will mehr
militärischen einsatz der französische
präsident bemängelt mit drastischen
worten die nato sei hirntot
was also wird da kommen in berlin gibt
es heute auf jeden fall eine ganze reihe
von entwicklungen die patrizia
wiedemeier zusammenfasst auch wenn es
eigentlich viele streitthemen gibt
zwischen den usa und deutschland beim
zweitägigen besuch von us aussenminister
von theo ist davon nichts zu spüren
erste gesprächspartnerin heute die
verteidigungsministerin dass die usa
mehr engagement von ihren nato partner
verlangen wird gerne jedes mal
wiederholt kramp karrenbauer sicherte
eine deutliche erhöhung der
verteidigungsausgaben bis 20 31 zu
das lob von compo folgte prompt bei
seiner rede vor der körber stiftung
warnte er dann vor den bedrohungen durch
russland oder china und widersprach dem
französischen präsidenten dass die nato
hirntod seit reform seien jedoch nötig
wenn die anderen mitgliedstaaten glauben
es gibt sicherheit ohne einen stärkeren
beitrag dann droht die nato ineffizient
oder gar obsolet zu werden
am nachmittag dann treffen mit der
bundeskanzlerin beide betonten sie seien
weiterhin freunde und enge partner bei
der lösung weltweiter krisen zum
beispiel in syrien und der ukraine
all das sind themen mit denen wir uns
heute beschäftigen werden und wo ich
ihnen sagen darf dass deutschland eine
aktive rolle spielen will
um diese probleme zu lösen deutschland
ist und bleibt ein sehr wichtiger
partner für uns ein neue
deutsch-amerikanischer kuschelkurs der
allerdings erst durch fakten belegt
werden müsse meint die opposition ich
finde der dialog zwischen deutschland
und den usa darf sich nicht auf
militärische beschränken sondern was
wichtig ist ist dass wir diplomatische
offensive machen um frieden
herbeizuführen zum beispiel in syrien
mit einer sicherheitszone am abend
verlässt der amerikanische außenminister
berlin die streitthemen sie werden wohl
bleiben trotz aller freundlichen worte
in den letzten zwei tagen eine ganze
reihe von gesetzen hat heute der
bundesrat beschlossen zum beispiel
sollen paketboten durch schärfer
bestrafen besser vor ausbeutung
geschützt werden falls ihre arbeitgeber
die sozialleistungen nicht korrekt
zahlen mehr geld soll es für
pflegekräfte geben der staat will
künftig eine tarifvereinbarung für die
ganze branche garantieren
beschlossen wurde auch die lange
umstrittene reform der grundsteuer habt
2025 wird sie nach einem neuen system
berechnet und wer hebamme werden will
muss künftig studieren das duale studium
dauert dann sechs bis acht semestern die
angehenden hebammen werden während des
studiums bezahlt
der asylantrag des libanesischen
clan-chefs ibrahimi ist von den
deutschen behörden abgelehnt worden
innenminister horst seehofer sagte jetzt
werde die erneute abschiebung
vorbereitet miri war es gelungen wieder
illegal nach deutschland einzureisen
nachdem er kurz zuvor als krimineller
abgeschoben worden war
der fall zeige dass das deutsche
rechtssystem in dem bereich anfällig für
missbrauch sei sagte seehofer und
kündigte änderungen
an im deutschen bundestag statt jetzt
einblick in ein land in dem es schon
seit wochen brodelt irak fast 300
menschen sind bereits ums leben gekommen
bei den demonstrationen die dort täglich
aufs neue aufnahmen worum geht es die
menschen wollen reformen arbeit ein
besseres leben
vor allem aber wollen sie einst nicht
von einem anderen land gesteuert werden
doch genau das werfen sie ihre regierung
vor eine marionette zu sein dass iran
immer schön berichtet wir werden nicht
weichen skandieren sie
bagdad am nachmittag tausende gehen
wieder auf die straße täglicher protest
gegen die zustände in irak
ich will dass die regierung aufhört uns
veränderungen zu versprechen das reicht
uns nicht sie sollen alle zurücktreten
hier sind lauter junge menschen die eine
gute ausbildung haben und keine chance
auf eine zukunft wir warten jetzt schon
seit 16 jahren auf den wandel und nichts
passiert seit wochen lehnen sich die
menschen in irak gegen die regierung und
deren misswirtschaft auf der staat
korrupt die infrastruktur marode
fließend wasser und strom gibt es nur
unregelmäßig für junge menschen kaum
perspektiven
die arbeitslosigkeit liegt bei 40
prozent doch inzwischen geht es auch um
anderes die demonstranten werfen der
schiitisch geprägten irakischen
regierung vor das land zunehmend dem
einfluss irans zu überlassen
vor fünf tagen griff eine aufgebrachte
menge das iranische generalkonsulat an
die führung in bagdad reagiert nervös
verspricht reformen lässt aber immer
wieder demonstrationen mit brutaler
gewalt auflösen
wir haben verständnis für friedliche
proteste aber wer das gesetz bricht und
gewalt ausübt muss streng bestraft
werden auch heute gibt es blutige
zusammenstöße
nach un angaben starben allein im monat
oktober mindestens 200 menschen gedenken
heute in berlin an die novemberpogrome
von 1938 dabei hatten die nazis etwa 800
juden ermordet synagogen geschäfte und
wohnungen zerstört bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier traf überlebende des
holocaust die erinnerung an die
ns-verbrechen bleibe eine fundamentale
aufgabe bei der es keinen schlussstrich
geben darf sorgt der regierende
bürgermeister von berlin michael müller
bange stunden heute in teutschenthal in
sachsen anhalt bei einer explosion in
einer grube sind zwei menschen verletzt
worden
das ehemalige kalibergwerk liegt bei
halle an der saale in den schächten
hatte sich wohl ein explosives
gasgemisch gebildet und entzündet 36
kumpel saßen vorübergehend fest in
sicherheits räumen mussten sie einige
stunden aushalten 700 meter unter der
erde am ende doch ein glimpflicher
ausgang thomas bärsch hat diese
geschichte in ersten meldungen heute
früh war von über 30 verschütteten
bergleuten die rede
ganz so dramatisch stellte sich die lage
vor ort nicht da
die kumpel hatten nach einer verpuffung
untertage sichere räume aufgesucht und
dort gewartet
es sind alle in der grube frei konnten
sich frei bewegen also nicht
eingeschlossen sondern einfach in den
ganz normalen pausenraum an die sich
eingesammelt so wie es ist meine kumala
ausgelöst wird zwei bergleute wurden
nachdem uns
ein krankenhaus gebracht die polizei
folgt dem protokoll
wie in solchen fällen üblich oder
erforderlich wird zum einen die polizei
ermitteln wir werden hier prüfen ob hier
möglicherweise jemand fahrlässig oder
vorsätzlich gehandelt hat was die
verpuffung verursachte ist unklar ein
verdacht wasserstoff die gruppe
deutschen teil für tiere hohlräume mit
sogenanntem versatz material mit
industrieabfällen eisen das in
mineralische abfälle die wir hier
versetzen unter tage ja zum großteil aus
der rauchgasreinigung von
müllverbrennungsanlagen ja und in diesem
jahr filterstäube ist halt auch unter
anderem auch wasserstoff gebunden
anwohner die seit jahren gegen die
einlagerung von industrieabfällen
kämpfen sehen sich durch den unfall
heute in ihrer skepsis bestätigt die
arbeit in der grube teutschenthal ruht
zurzeit die ermittlungen werden sich
über das wochenende hinziehen
und dann haben wir dramatische bilder
heute aus australien dort sind dutzende
buschfeuer außer kontrolle geraten
besonders betroffen die bundesstaaten
new south wales und queensland durch
starke winde breiten sich die feuer so
schnell aus dass bewohner mancher
gebiete von fluchtwegen abgeschnitten
sind
die behörden rieten den anwohnern schutz
zu suchen normen odenthal berichtet er
sieht aus wie im krieg ein kampf ist es
allemal aus dem feuerwehr hubschrauber
wird das ganze in ferne sichtbar und
bleibt doch schwer zu begreifen
ich muss zugeben dass wir so was noch
nie hatten noch nie gab es so viele
feuer auf diesen katastrophal niveau
allein im bundesstaat new south wales
brennen 90 50 sind außer kontrolle
sie breiten sich aus sie kommen immer
näher
rasant unberechenbar nimmt die feuerwehr
die lage ortschaften seien in höchster
gefahr
und manche fluchtwege nicht mehr lange
offen
meine sachen sind gepackt vielleicht
muss ich in zehn minuten hier raus
vielleicht habe ich noch eine halbe
stunde ich weiß nicht monatelang teils
jahrelang hat diese ecke des landes
keinen tropfen regner bekommen wälder
und büsche brennen wie zunder dieser
koala hat sich die nase versenkt und
großes glück gehabt retter haben ihn
gefunden und versorgt
wir haben hier ein naturschutzgebiet mit
600 koalas zwei drittel des reservats
sind abgebrannt etwa 350 tiere tot
bei temperaturen von mehr als 800 grad
hatten sie keinen schutz
kein regen in sicht und australiens
sommer hat noch gar nicht richtig
begonnen mit wohlig könnten die
aussichten kaum sein
ganz so zeigen die bilder sehr
eindrücklich jetzt mal ein schritt in
der sendung kommen zum sport und damit
zu dir christin deutsche clasico steht
bevor erster spieltag der gipfel der
bundesliga bayern münchen empfängt
borussia dortmund diesmal nicht der
erste sondern der vierte gegen den
zweiten der noch das gigantentreffen bei
dem nur eins zählt der sieg die stimmung
bei bvb gelöst gleichzeitig aber auch
angespannt man muss zu den bayern dort
seit 2014 kann sieht man der bundesliga
22 gegentore kassiert aber die jüngsten
leistungen machen hoffnung
wir müssen männer fußball spielen wir
müssen kerle seien am samstag auf dem
platz darum wird es gehen preuß und
sancho vielen wohl den bvb und mats
hummels der wird sich vornehmlich um
lewandowski kümmern getroffen hat dieser
bisher in jedem bundesligaspiel er ist
bayerns faustpfand dortmund das ist die
ziellinie
ja und die wollen wir wirklich auch da
wo man durchgehend mit dem sieg nach dem
debakel in frankfurt während drei punkte
balsam für die angeschlagene bayern
seele und erste free tv bilder vom
top-spiel in aller ausführlichkeit
morgen abend im aktuellen sportstudio
von 23 uhr an
frust und freude bei den deutschen
verein in der europa league während
wolfsburg und frankfurt durch
niederlagen herbe rückschläge verkraften
müssen
meldet sich borussia mönchengladbach im
kampf ums weiterkommen eindrucksvoll
zurück gladbach im kollektiven
freudentaumel nach einem erneut
dramatischen sieg in der europa dieses
mal in der fünften minute der
nachspielzeit durch türen der mit dem 2
1-siegtor gladbach das zuvor schon
zweimal in europa so später ein spiel
drehen konnte
alle möglichkeiten auf ein weiterkommen
lässt enttäuschung dagegen war der
frankfurter eintracht philipp kostet
chatten lüttich in der nachspielzeit das
2 1 erzielen können wenn nicht sogar
müssen im direkten gegenzug bekamen die
belgier zum 2 2 1 erfolg durch lässt ihn
dadurch droht der eintracht jetzt das
aus nach der gruppenphase einen krimi
glich das spitzenspiel der
handball-bundesliga mit dem glücklichen
ende für die rhein neckar löwen trotz
des zeitweiligen sieben tore rückstands
gingen die gäste vom rekordmeister thw
kiel entschieden die löwen nach einer
unglaublichen aufholjagd diese partie
mit 26 25 doch noch für sich
danach ging es weiter mit dieser party
sie freuen sich auf jeden fall so
christine muss jetzt in einem
sommerlichen outfit ganz tapfer sein
denn es geht richtung winter schnee
fällt nicht mehr nur ganz weit oben
sondern auch in den mittelgebirgen aber
sonne es am wochenende auch mit dabei
mehr gleich von katja hornuf das heute
journal mit dem kollegen claus kleber um
21.45 und wir sind auch morgen abend am
9 november hier für sie da
danke schon mal für ihr interesse heute
und in allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren ganz
unterschiedlich war das wetter heute
strahlenden sonnenschein gab es für die
einen bei temperaturen von zehn oder elf
grad im südwesten dagegen winter dass
ich richtig ein
im schwarzwald und auf der alb hat es
viel geschneit klippeneck zum beispiel
meldete uns 13 cm schnee und schneeregen
begleiten uns im südwesten auch durch
die nacht und es kann bis auf 500 meter
herunter schneien glatt kann es
allerdings auch im westen werden bei
temperaturen von plus 2 bis minus 1 grad
wenn der nebel am boden festfrieren
eindeutig zu mit für glätte bleibt es
nordöstlich der elbe bei
tiefsttemperaturen von 8 bis 5 grad
der regen der nacht zieht weiter nach
norden und erreicht schon am frühen
morgen mecklenburg vorpommern morgen
mittag dann wird es in berlin und
brandenburg aufhören zu regnen
nachmittags gibt es dann einige
regenschauer auch wieder im saarland
oder in rheinland pfalz am
freundlichsten aber morgen wird es
zwischen dem oberrhein und der
nordseeküste und die temperaturen
steigen auf werte zwischen 4 grad am
alpenrand und im vogtland und 9 grad an
der ostsee und entlang des rheins der
sonntag wird sehr freundlich für uns
alle
bei temperaturen von 4 bis 10 schönes
wochenende